[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wollte nach hause einfach wie du
willst hause mann du hast 450.000
geworden muster feiern einen draufmachen
hat hinter tumor ohmann class ist auch
eine arm ist auch so ein looser aber
lose mit 250.000 euro dass ich ihn dann
an meine ballack ist aber logisch und es
gibt bei mir nach möglichkeit das geld
aus möglichkeiten das geld auszugeben
und vor allem da mit 80.000
anführungszeichen so auf klaas also auf
buback in klasse ganz kurzfristig glaube
darüber wie hilf mir folgende sind
anstrengend als sport und hilf mir
selbst hat den kommentar an gewinnt ich
bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob ich das
jetzt gut oder schlecht finden soll
was soll man dazu sagen sollte man kann
es auch über nachvollziehen poker klar
es hat natürlich eindeutiger weise style
und das geld nach dieser waffen sind das
die qualitäten die frauen in einem
ansuchen deswegen kann ich diese dame
hier sehr gut verstehen weil dieser
staat ist auch richtig liebl alter
hingucken nicht hingucken bleibt halt
san sebastian ernst was ich mich frage
ist die findet man darsteller sie sich
bereitete in der rtl2 hilf mir folgende
prostituierte zu spielen kleine so ich
mache ich jetzt schon teilweise ja wie
untermalung mein interview ist hart
genug und normale rolle zu spielen aber
aber wenn gesagt wird du spielst du
[ __ ] hammer ich bin im siebten himmel
carsten hatte recht ist super ich bin
kein loser mehr ich bin poker tinkler
er ist poken class a der spruch von
macht es übrigens fast zu passend hilfe
von irgendwie ich hab keinen bock drauf
weil egal so was passiert der folge man
kann eigentlich fast immer mit deftigen
aja kommentieren was auch gern was ich
mir vorstelle thema vorher hätte zwei
wer so was erleben manche gab es oft
ganz entspannt mit 5 million gewonnen
hängt damit den damen in diesem
etablissement ab und dann muss man
einfach so wieder weg dar und ein
statement abgeben
so soll der antrag oder kann klar kann
man sein leben genießen
warum muss jetzt für die kamera das
kommentieren könnt ihn doch einfach mal
leute klar es wird hier nicht fair
behandelt schmecken sie doch einfach mal
ein paar kilo ab und an geht das auch
alles ein bisschen schneller
wieder zeigt
ok wo sind wir jetzt hatte jemand den
schnitt verstanden was was ist das
welche frau wer redet da mit dieser frau
wer ist dieser mann werden diese frau
macht klasse mit dem mülheimer ist jetzt
nicht euer ernst ist jetzt gerade nicht
euer ernst
leute das wir müssen unser schutz können
auch ziehen bitte alle zu hause jetzt
einmal kurze pause drei sekunden und
prinz brille anziehen weil ohne
schutzausrüstung kann man sich das hier
jetzt echt nicht mehr anschauen
sie haben in meinem büro gar nichts
verloren in meinem büro geht niemand
alleine ohne dass ich es nicht weiß und
was soll das hier mit dem eimer und der
offenen hose ja ja ja wir falsch gemacht
die ersten fünf minuten entwickeln auf
jeden fall lust auf die in ihrer
handlung definitiv schlüssig ist
18-jähriger gewinnt eine viertelmillion
euro und kackt wenige minuten später
einem völlig fremden land in seinen mit
fernsehen 2009/10 gucken sie doch nach
machen sie den scheiß haben sie daran
gedacht oder weise ja immer gerne
gesehen oder also bleibt ihr wird er
nicht reingelegt haben dinge
er mag einzelhandel kann dann wird der
zweite künstler geben ich glaube meine
reifen haben kann es noch rein kommst du
ich bin poker kein klares und lasse mir
von keinem mehr was sagen hoch erklärt
was ist jetzt politik und der krieg
poker ging klar als was ist das
wer wissen will wo er seine brille es
ist poker king klar ist vor zehn minuten
viertelmillion euro
wie kannst du als mitarbeiter der
örtlichen sparkasse oder nicht
mitbekommen haben dass irgend
achtjähriger von zehn minuten mit
millionen gewandert ist ein dummkopf
es ist so glauben nur morde wir noch
rein muss ihren fünf jahre beschließen
kommen sie mal bitte ganz schnell auf
die registrierten möglich auch wenn das
jetzt sehr schmerzhaft ist für mich und
es ist anstrengend als sport für den
kommentar muss ich auf jeden fall an der
stelle mal zustimmung geben
für diese anwendung läuft begrüßen wir
mit tobendem applaus in der sammlung der
einwendung auf unserem kanal
reingeschossen reingeschossen
gucken sie mal was ihr freund gemacht
hat können sie sich das erklären wussten
sie davon
sie hängen doch sonst immer mit ihm nun
eine strecke wirklich nicht passen sie
mal auf
ich sage ihnen jetzt mal ja
wahrscheinlich wird er an der stelle
noch mal unterstreichen dass er pokert
in class ist da plötzlich mit der
mutation nicht verstanden
und außerdem was für eine grauenhafte
hemd krawatten kommen jetzt nun ist das
leader deshalb mit dunkelblauer krawatte
liga aber ich muss sagen dieses outfit
finde ich tatsächlich katastrophal
jennifer damit nichts zu tun und lassen
sie ihre angestellten war vernünftig von
den behandlungen und hiermit kündige
hält und wie sie kündigen sie machen
ihren scheiß weg aber warum arbeitet
klar ist jetzt auch bei dem drei seiner
freunde ist also sozusagen paris
gekündigt oder dazu arbeiten aber gut zu
europa kindern class chef hat
offensichtlich recht behalten die class
baut nur scheiße und das im wahrsten
sinne des wortes was ist das für eine
geile meile wahlweise muss man sagen
wirklich die kommentatoren bei it messe
sogar aber das ist ja deren status ihren
status und bis aufs aller geist ist das
habe ich der letzten folge nicht gesagt
der tipp wie man hier sieht der ist
wirklich anwalt in düsseldorf menschen
leicht gesenkt ziemlich schnell werde
jetzt die schriftliche kündigung noch
erfolgt ist diese damit wirksam
damit muss der chef sich nicht nur um
einen neuen mülleimer kümmern sondern
auch um einen neuen mitarbeiter
[Musik]
wie soll ich die brille gezogen leute
die ja wo es echt schwer kostet das ist
jetzt das ist wirklich harte arbeit
anstrengender als sport trifft
tatsächlich ziemlich gut oder um es mit
den worten von unserem geliebten
brillenträger zusagen macht ihr das mit
ihren jetzt gebt euch mal hier sind
gesicht hier und das ist glas vater hier
mit dem otto von bismarck gedenkt bat
der längst ja auch ach du heilige
scheiße nach außen gleich im doppelpack
du weißt du ich meine wenn man sowieso
schon mal hier nach so ich habe auch
immer so
okay ist dass die normale reaktion von
dem fahrrad nach hause kommt unseren
sohn mit zwei beruflichen der gewisse
richtung tätigen frauen findet ist die
erste reaktion des fahrers dann also ich
hab eine verspannung also habe ich
gesagt du alleine mit 2 und ich habe
auch immer so macken haben das ja auch
normal so also jeder mensch hat im
nacken
in der regel aus wenn jemand sagt so
drückt ja jeder homo sapiens hatten
rücken also ich weiß was es bedeutet
aber die formulierung ist natürlich
immer ein bisschen
1000 unter männer und du bist du sparst
du bist im nacken
was hier ja dann setzt sich gar noch
dazu
ja keine nachfragen so werden diese
frauen was machen sie hier warum sind
alle gefühlt nackt in dieser szene ein
richtiger vater der seinen sohn achtet
haut sich direkt mit zwischen den noten
das reicht nicht
quint wirte und händler vor es reicht
nicht es reicht mich leute die queen
strahlung ist einfach zu stark
genieß das jetzt mal egal
ja das ist wirklich nicht mehr normal
das ist wirklich nicht mehr da war ganz
ernst ich glaube es ist noch mal eine
ganze ecke schlimmer als die
allermeisten erfolgen die wir bisher
gesehen haben
die letzte folge die man auch hart kommt
ist ihm die chemie hat wehgetan auf
jeden fall aber das geschehen dass er
sollte von dieser folge leute wie man
möchte mich entschuldigen riskiert diese
schmerzen meine lippen gehabt weiter das
völlig vorgeschlagenes videochat das ab
und bis zum nächsten mal
bleibt stark